em taió
eu sem maquiagem tá eu confio 397 eu com
maquiagem feita pelo r7
eu não sei nem se eu não sou eu que
estou jogando agora passei ontem eu num
filme chamado risco duplo de janeiro
afirma já ver o é uma bosta de filmes
gente não podia falar bosta agora falei
é é um filme é muito bom tá bom é não
recomendando mas é um filme de cada vez
que passa na televisão e passa muito eu
paro tudo o que estiver fazendo a
assistir essa mulher e as leis onde ela
foi enganada pelo marido marido foi dar
um golpe no seguro ela incriminou ela
foi parar na cadeia passou anos na
cadeia pública estava viva ela saiba se
vingar e eu desliguei negócio é e e é
uma coisa que acontece quando eu vejo
esse filme é parece que estou lá dentro
parece que eu sou é semelhante parece
que eu sinto as coisas que sente e dá
raiva medo angústia me dá desespero às
vezes eu me afasto um pouco falou
vai lá vai lá e j andando rápido e é
essa relação é uma coisa que a
humanidade faz a gente sempre tem a
capacidade de lidar com ficção
isso vem desde os primórdios da
humanidade né
já viram criança conta desenhando e
acontece toda uma ação ali no papel em
tempo real que ela fala aí ele veio pra
cá e vira um grande empurrão e ela mata
a mãe falou 'mãe desenha me falando que
linda não ficou muito legal mas ali
acontecer um monte de coisa
da mesma maneira os os humanos na pré
história quando em fazê-la arte rupestre
nas cavernas ali de alguma maneira já
estão se projetando naquele desenho né
mesmo que fosse uma representação da
realidade a hora que você faz uma
representação já é uma outra coisa
o tempo todo a gente está se perguntando
quem eu seria né
o tempo todo a gente se pergunta quem eu
seria se eu tivesse 10 milhões
eu seria se eu tivesse num acidente de
avião se eu morasse na etiópia o tempo
todo a gente está fazendo essa simulação
é claro que é uma mentira né a gente não
consegue estar no lugar de outra pessoa
a gente só pode ser a gente mesmo
mas na hora que eu simulo na minha
cabeça eu tô ampliando a minha visão de
mundo eu tô conseguindo essa
característica ligada à empatia tá
ligada à capacidade de formular
hipóteses de prevê desfechos para
situações e é ea nossa imagem o que a
gente produz imagem com a gente mesmo no
mundo é uma ficção também né
quando você se veste de um certo jeito
quando você gesticulou de uma certa
forma você está propondo para as pessoas
que elas vejam de você o que você queria
mostrar isso é uma ficção
eu fui percebendo na vida desde
criancinha quando entrei na escola que
existia principalmente em relação ao
gênero é é um estatuto de regras muito
malucas que eu não conhecia e que se
você não seguir esse estatuto que
determinava exatamente tudo o que o
menino precisa fazer jamais em hipótese
alguma se assemelhar a uma mulherzinha
você essa violência está tudo maluco qsi
mugen tinha regra por exemplo você sabia
que não podia chupar picolé
você podia comprar picolé se podia
chegar no colégio picolé de lamber o
picolé
você podia morrer o picolé você não
podia chupar é coisa de
era um menino uma vez tony recebeu juro
por deus é a gente estava brincando e
jogando bola de gude e aí ele é um pouco
mais velho que eu acho que tinha uns 13
anos e ele falou
sabia que meu pai me deixou colocar um
brinco legal
aí ele falou como se tivesse perguntado
na orelha esquerda na época na orelha
direita é
e isso gente o que que acontece com o
contato do metal neste lobolo que não
acontece nesse da onde que vem essas
bobagens que a gente está vendo com isso
o tempo todo
pensa é a mulher que ela se sente menos
feminina quando ela corta o cabelo
porque o porquê de nós então que ela
saia porque a gente está lidando com
essas regras o tempo todo como se elas
fossem de verdade e o coletivo ele reage
com muita violência quando a imagem que
ele espera de você
não é que você dá todo mundo aqui lembra
por exemplo da história da geisy arruda
se lembra disso
quem lembra lembra né a geisy arruda foi
isso ela foi à faculdade com um
vestidinho que ela achou bacana nisso
toda a coletividade sentindo direito de
interferir com elas de gritar e xingar
de passar a mão
graças a deus não soube capitalizar com
isso e eu quero que ganhem muito
dinheiro mas é eu vou mostrar a vocês um
cara aí a sua imagem uma ficção já
passei da parede não dá pra ter muito
nessa imagem pequenininho
é isso aí é um desenho de um cara de um
artista brasileiro chamado flávio de
carvalho favor não confundir com a lava
o flávio de carvalho é desses caras
multitalentosos era arquiteto escritor
poeta e ele ficava incomodado a questão
dele não era nem gênero ele tava falando
de outra coisa ele está no comando do
brasileiro ao se investir e produzir
europeu fazer
só que o nosso clima né a gente passa
calor a gente vive na unidade e usava
terno e gravata ele é só mais uma
bactéria não vai sumir de notícias ea em
57 ele propôs esse traço aí a ser o caso
do brasileiro
e aí está não dá para ver direito mas
ele vai continuar pensando de uma
maneira bem pragmática uma roupa que
seja fácil lavar que não sul e ele fala
que sirva a gordos e magros diminui as
guerras ele fala que a pessoa fica mais
livre e aí nesse ano mesmo ele saiu à
rua com o trabalho dele e eu queria que
vocês observassem essa movimentação em
volta do do flávio de carvalho em 2014
art
aí o yuri pode meu amigo é fez essa
roupa chamava biquíni quadradão porque é
feito de quadrados no tecido e isso é
ele andando no porto da barra em
salvador e tem na internet vídeos e são
procuradas na chapa é e as reações são
as mais estapafúrdia a gente dá risada
tem gente que filma a gente vai atrás
dele e sei que joga coisa que a gente
que bate a gente chuta e que sociedade é
essa que a gente cria com essas regras
não é com esse estatuto é de conduta
completamente aleatório e completamente
sem sentido que faz com que uma pessoa
diante disso diante de uma roupa que não
se considera adequada porque o ambiente
acho que o melhor a fazer é dar um chute
é bater em alguém mas a nossa sociedade
né a humanidade sempre achando jeito
subvertê esses estatutos
isso daí a imagem a gente não sabe
direito de quem quer mas é de alguém é
na segunda guerra em muito pouca
informação sobre essas e mais um
pesquisador alemão descobriu por acaso
ano passado mas sua imagem da segunda
guerra
bem é nos campos nazistas
a gente não sabe se são soldados são
gays ou héteros não tem muita informação
sobre eles
essa imagem isso aqui é no estado de
nova york nos estados unidos do interior
tinha essa casa chamada casa susana isso
ali no finalzinho começo dos anos 60 é
era uma casa que ela hospedaria em que
as pessoas pagavam passar uns dias em
que não pudessem se vestir de mulher né
os homens podiam lá estar vestidos de
mulher e conviver e tomar um chá e passa
pelo campo a gente também não sabe se
eram gays em pessoa sttrans que na época
era tudo muito muito misturado né
aqui no brasil a gente sempre teve o
carnaval o carnaval sempre foi um espaço
onde a gente podia dar uma bolada
nessa regra como nos estados unidos e
tem o halloween é também um espaço onde
se pode mudar um pouquinho as coisas
em 47 mas a gente tem registro desde o
século 17 a gente tem registro desse
tipo de baile de fim de festa baile de
sujos onde os homens se vestem de mulher
é gente já aconteceu desde o primeiro
carnaval no rio de janeiro já tinha isso
as mulheres nunca tiveram muito acesso á
a poder fazer esse tipo de transformação
com a própria imagem né
sempre fui mais restrito a elas e o
carnaval foi a origem de muitas drag
queens no brasil
uma delas é essa laura divison é uma
figura importantíssima para o brasil
a laura é uma artista que ela criou uma
cena no rio de janeiro nos anos 70 e 80
porque ela chamava as pessoas a
participar do show e fazer show e laura
é ela tinha um tipo de trabalho
performático que estava muito mais
próximo ao meu ver das artes visuais das
artes plásticas do que do que a gente
conhece de ver quem normalmente ela
fazer performance que eram muito é
bizarras e provocativas e etc e mas a
gente não vai ver ela nos livros de
história da arte nem a gente não tem uma
história da arte com a drag e ela a
laura durante o dia era essa pessoa aqui
é um professor de história numa escola
de ensino fundamental
essa imagem é de um documentário da
antiga tv manchete
neste documentário ela fala que ela se
sentirá vestida quando eu estava sim
isso pra ela era uma ficção
pra mim é um pouco diferente uma coisa
que vou descobrindo nesses dez anos aí
circulando pelo brasil e conhecendo
travestis drag queen é transformistas e
pesquisando essa história é que para
cada pessoa que faz isso
a relação entre ficção e realidade é
como se fosse uma digital é totalmente
única
cada pessoa tem um jeito muito
particular de lidar com isso
pra mim o tal montar nada acabou virando
uma mistura só eu não sou é ea sensação
de thatta vestida não está tão ligada a
roupa enquanto a 1
a mudança no olhar aquele momento que eu
me afastei e óleo fala o que quer
acha que é a hora que eu sinto que eu
não estou confortável na minha pele né
mas desde os 16 anos queria montar a que
ocorra essa coisinha que tristeza isso
ainda com 16 anos é eu não queria contar
pra vocês não contou para ninguém mas
com 16 anos eu saía da boate
eu tinha um amigo chamado crise é a
gente ia junto com as boates gays e eu
sou das greves e adorava jogar em casa e
montar o criciúma câmera a gente fazer
vários filmes uns só não deixava de
mostrar a ninguém porque eu tinha
vergonha não tanto porque eu tivesse
medo é de uma reação homofóbica de
apanhar porque isso já acontecia isso aí
quando a minha vida inteira e eu sabia
revidar bem é mais do que eu tinha um
pouco de preconceito com status do
trabalho da equipe e eu achava um
trabalho menor eu achava um trabalho sem
intelectualidade e é uma coisa que
depois quando fui conhecer mais a fundo
eu fui vendo que era uma tremenda
bobagem da minha parte eu mas nessa
época havia muitos shows dessas aí são
das primeiras equipes do brasil e
começaram é a cena que em curitiba
vitória principal dilson zona de tiboli
lê é talita mouse entre outras eram as
minhas inspirações que a gente tava
pegando o comecinho da cena andré guiné
antes a gente falava em transformista e
aí com um filme priscila
o hubble lá na metade dos anos 90 a
gente vai começar a falar em drag queen
e ela estava entre as primeiras que a
gente tem aqui foi montada pela primeira
vez
só depois dos 30 eu sei que o preso tem
17 mas não é verdade
e aí lá em salvador
não é porque eu já estava ligando muito
menos a opinião dos outros num bar
chamado âncora do marujo essa foi a
primeira vez no mundo todo de uma vez e
maravilhosa da marina garden que faleceu
há pouco tempo atrás o ativista
inteligentíssima generosa incrível e aí
olha que o ro
isso aqui vocês estão vendo isso na
minha cabeça eu achava que eu estava sim
a minha inspiração é essa cantora mina
a italiana que eu adorava e eu queria
fazer um gol igual ao dela e uma coisa
muito engraçada desse trabalho é que
quando você pega a ficção e e coloca no
teu corpo tem que ligar lidar com todas
essas limitações com erro porque não deu
certo como que não ajustou e isso é uma
característica que eu adoro porque vai
fazendo com que eu me transforme e eu
falo de tudo isso é aqui hoje para vocês
na esperança de que a gente entenda que
esse trabalho que eu faço aqui apesar de
ser mais evidente é a mesma coisa que
todo mundo faz né a gente o tempo todo
sendo ficção
então se dá pra tirar alguma coisa
dessas pessoas que já aconteceram antes
da gente fizer o trabalho da gente é que
tem muita regra que j no mundo que a
gente não precisa fixar nelas que a
gente pode ter uma maneira muito mais
leve né pra que você tem que deixar o
cabelo daquele jeito precisa se
acostumar a chácara era você mas não é
meu cabelo é você né porque está naquela
relação que não gosta mais porque você
não pode sair das coisas e voltar eu
acho que é isso que eu queria contar pra
vocês hoje desculpas e me afobei um
pouquinho e um é isso
[Aplausos]
[Música]